hey smart how are you morgan hey
um so fans have been waiting eagerly for
season four
of swat there's so much excitement
surrounding this premiere a two-hour
premiere
uh what are you excited for fans to see
i love that we're coming out of the gate
with two hours you know swat is back
in your face um yeah no it's been
it's three seasons so far and the fans
have loved us you know canada has loved
us
canada has given me love my whole career
so shout out to canada
oh yeah i'm right back uh from my young
and restless days to criminal minds now
swat
uh yeah it's been a fun ride and canada
has shown me a lot of love
i love i love it you know my
grandmother's french was french canadian
she was going to quebec city outside of
montreal yeah
quebec city or canada montreal
so back to season four um
you know this is this is a this is a i
mean
this is an exciting year because cbs and
sony
and swat is being bold and brave we're
always going to give you that signature
we're always going to give you that
thrill ride that's what swat is you know
super cops chasing the bad guys
motorcycle chases car chases
hello hondo hanging off the side of a
helicopter
you know hand-hand combat you know that
that tough guy that honda scowl that i
do
we're gonna we're gonna give you that
but also you know it's a different time
for everybody around the world
with covet um so it's been tricky to
make the show
uh following all the protocols getting
tested you know sometimes i feel like a
lab rat
because i'm getting tested so much with
the q-tips in the nose and
you know and then coughing into a
confidence fit into a cup
and getting my temperature taken all the
time on set you got to wear masks with
face shields the crews all
barely know what anybody looks like um
but we're incorporating covet
and then what was very important to me
is we're incorporating the racial
injustices that are happening
around this country and around the world
you know taking on
taking on the truths of george floyd and
ahmad aubry
brianna taylor blake um i just made it
you know i talked to
i talked to all my executives and i said
i can't be a black man
uh in real life i can't be a black black
man in an lapd
or form on swat and not be conscious and
not address these issues
and literally the day or so after that
george floyd lost his life
i called all of them we had a big
meeting and i said what are we going to
do with this show
we are we wear the uniform the people
watching the news um
in this country and around the world
where there's division there's there's
fear
there's all this unrest between the
police and civilians
we gotta promote optimism we but we also
got to tell the truth
um so in the first episode of season
four
um we talk about watts in 1992 we talk
about the riots
uh we talk about rodney king uh and then
in the parallels of what's happening 28
years later with george floyd and the
others
with the peaceful protest uh some aren't
so peaceful
so literally in one hour of television
which will continue through subsequent
episodes through the season um i'm proud
that we're addressing
uh the struggles that we're going
through and
and and telling the truth that there are
bad bad apples in law enforcement but
predominantly they fight for good uh
beyond the badge
are human beings who are flawed but
still but still
fight for basic goodness you know we
talk about bridging the gap between
black and blue hondo being a black man
trying to stay true to his community uh
but wanting to promote
and promote change within law
enforcement unify and create
and create a better temperament uh more
equality
uh we talk about the divide between the
cops and civilians
and trying to create some understanding
present both sides
um so that's for television to be able
to do that
um is bigger than me it's bigger than
swat
um it's really powerful and uh i'm proud
of
of what what what we're trying to do
with swat and i think we're being i
think we're very successful
i was just going to ask i mean you have
been a working actor for a number of
years you've worked on amazing projects
but it must feel very special to be
working
on a show that is addressing what is
happening in the world that will mean
something to people when they watch this
yeah it's it's i mean it's you know
again
we're never going to preach to you we're
not a political show we're not we're not
a religious show
um but we're i take a lot of pride in
that we're
trying to be a woke show um so we deal
with all different kind of issues but
right now the issue at hand
uh is coven and these racial injustices
and and
you know if i as a black man on
television
um i i pride myself
on being
promoting promoting
togetherness i you know i'm not blind i
see color but i was raised by my mother
to see past color i'm not going to judge
you because of your color i'm
judging because of who you are your
actions um
and i think we need more of that in law
enforcement i think we need more of that
uh just as human beings you know i it
may sound corny but janet jackson once
upon a time said
you know in complete darkness we are all
the same it is only our knowledge and
wisdom that separates us don't let your
eyes deceive you
and i i took it i heard that when i was
in college
and i clearly i've memorized it and i
believe it
um you know martin luther king judged by
and you know
judged my character you know and uh
i just think swat is in a perfect
position
and me as hondo have a ideal opportunity
to tell stories and give messaging that
messaging that a lot of shows
may not be able to may not be able to do
like we can
because we are swat yeah um you know
it's four seasons
you've been with this character now how
much do you love playing hondo
because the viewers love you they feel
so connected with you but but how much
do you love playing this character
well you know i always say you know
without young and the restless you know
malcolm witches that vino criminal minds
derek morgan
and baby girls baby girl
that's never going away that's never
going away so you know 27 years in the
game
you know i love my evolution you know
i'm very proud of my journey
uh and then here i am the lead of squat
um
and i'm proud i'm proud to have
accomplished to be able to be the lead
and be a leader but
you know i'm not trying to say all the
right things but i'm always my mother
and still you go stay humble boy you're
gonna stay humble but i know that i
can't do it by myself i know it's not
all about me
it takes a team uh but without derrick
morgan on criminal minds you know i was
on
the criminal launch for 11 years kicking
down doors and chasing bad guys
that basically was just practice to be
honda and uh and hondo
i always say is just derek morgan on
steroids you know
not not just not just not just
physically but just
i mean honda's a bet a bad man i would
say mom
here come that man and uh you know i got
my hundo voice i got my honda voice
hondo's real serious you know shamar i
got the big old
goofy smile i have a lot more fun than
some of these characters
i played but uh but you know but if
hondo and shamara got in the fight
game over shamar i'm on my back um
but it's fun it's fun to be as it's kind
of like i'm a superhero without a cape
you know and but i'm a real life
superhero and and and
honestly like the men and women of law
enforcement we've met we got we've met a
lot of them and we got trained by them
um so we don't want to just be cool
actors running around with you know
fake guns you know uh we actually want
to bring a lot of authenticity and we
want to
pay homage to the men and women of law
enforcement who truly
risk their lives every day to protect
people and risk not going
home to their families so there is a
very serious serious element to
what we're doing and what we're
portraying so you know to be the badass
but with humanity um is is really fun to
play
well i cannot wait for the premiere uh
congrats on this season
and yeah it should be should be quite a
ride